hey guys angry Joe hair at Gamescom 2016
i'm joined by Michael Hardy has a guy
mike goodes more we just played recall
right yeah all of us you played it
before I Ethan you've got a more updated
version of it I saw the combat I'm
familiar with the combat you've seen new
mechanics doing yeah they showed us an
early mission in the campaign it kind of
highlights how the games Metroid Prime
influences what with developers from
metro and from coming over to wreak or
to help out keiji inafune a and the rest
of the team it showed how the metroid
prime influence are playing into this
semi open world that's kind of gated by
certain abilities they have to get and
then you'll be backtracking but also a
loop best kind of aspect yeah so they've
they've been alluding to that for a
while like the cause and you know
customizing them but thus far they've
not ready talked about it so what do
they actually show you is there any sort
of like depth to it yeah so you have
those five core bots that's like the dog
you see initially in the trailer the
first trailer then there's a spider
there's the gorilla one I believe his
name is Duncan but those are actually
the cores themselves like the spheres so
you switch those around those are like
the souls of the robot Katie Mifune was
saying during this demo you swap those
in two different bodies and frames and
it's the frames that you customized you
can give like the gorilla hammer arms to
make it more powerful you can give the
dog this like distance or the spider
sorry this distant like stun gun right
and you find new pieces of loot around
the world that enemies drop you can
either shoot her jewels grappling hook
at them and pull them out for a
potential new core or you can just
destroy them for new parts and naturally
you'll start finding you know different
tiers of items based on their color you
know in purple being a legendary it's
the classic like Diablo kind of move
fest angle they're taking with that cool
and I found it like the combat was quite
dynamic in the films of it wants you to
switch between all these robots at the
same time so like with those those kind
of new abilities because like there's
going to be a lot of depth to the combi
in terms of we had that Ikaruga element
as well
you know you have these items and
abilities and weapons that you need to
color match almost like does just add
more to the combat do you find a little
bit on the surface yeah you'll be
upgrading jewels rifles separately from
your core BOTS and you'll fight enemies
that are either red blue or yellow some
of the primary colors that also plays
into the core bots you'll find like red
blue yellow fours and then you'll find
like the combination colors a crippled
green they're really going in this color
aspect but by switching to the color of
the enemy like shooting a red enemy with
red you'll do more damage and then say
your dog robot because you can only have
two robots on a mission at a time right
out of 5 that they've announced say your
daughter about stuns one of them you
start shooting with a red rifle it's
gonna hurt that more but then you see a
bunch of those yellow airborne like
drone rora enemies there for that you
want switch to yellow you'll do more
damage yeah yeah I found it was like a
nice mix of puzzle and actually like
moments moment in direct combat with
platforming like you did you feel like
it's you know kind of like a
well-rounded type game yeah it's kind of
that influence the Megaman influence
right edge including they've been saying
you know it's not a megaman game but it
does feel like a 3d megaman that it
combines platforming in pretty difficult
combat that I found your jumping your
air dashing your dashing on the ground
you're kind of like strafing from side
to side feel very much like kind of a
megaman mixed with a Metroid Prime in
terms of the world right and then of
course like I don't know if you want to
make another comparison the Diablo luton
oh yeah yeah i think the the debate that
i found most challenging was the boss
and it's the part where it most reminded
me of megaman as well this is flying
like wolf type monster and just
constantly pumping out the flying see
you be sly like enemies they just need
to constantly shoot and look for the
weak point kind of grapple and put it
and it required a lot of like
maneuvering around to try and find the
right we point and kind of hit at the
right time as well as managing different
like platforms and traps in my counsel
it felt really good to me and my back at
easier said it's probably the megaman
game in looking for considering my
number 9 was a bit of a
and you know it he's living in the
shadow of Mega Man and people always
want that and I personally feel like if
you maybe look at this yeah keep an eye
on this it's not going to be 2d
obviously but yeah could be something
that might like also sate your hunger
for like a new metroid prime oh yeah
yeah I never liked structured over the
world the spirit of mega man is in there
somewhere I'm good let's recall across
III and game film for more on the game
and overall coverage of games from 2016
keep Aaron gamespot com